let's say that many years ago you've
started yourself a nice little business
you have no debt and your business every
year generates a pre-tax income of a
million and a half a year and a third of
that goes to taxes so you get a nice one
million dollars a year of net income
it's a super stable business nothing
risky over here just by virtue of what
your business does the odds of this one
million year changing for the better or
the worst isn't that likely so this is
essentially your this is what your
balance sheet would look like these are
your assets you have no debt let's
assume you have no liabilities and so
you own all of the equity you
essentially own all of the assets but
you're nearing retirement and you want
to kind of cash out you don't
necessarily want to sell to your
competitors or maybe there aren't any
natural competitors to sell to because
you've been
well
you don't want to sell to them if they
exist because you're competing with them
for your for your whole life and this
isn't the type of business that you can
ipo because it's not quite big enough so
maybe we bump into each other and say
hey this business looks interesting i
like the idea that your business is
stable it can generate a lot of income
year after year after year so what i say
is hey would you be willing to take 10
million dollars for your business so i
offer
i offer
10 million dollars and to you that
sounds pretty good that's about 10 times
that's exactly 10 times your yearly net
income this isn't a growing business
just very stable seems like a reasonable
deal to you
on the other hand for me i'm like you
know paying 10 million dollars and
getting a million dollars a year that's
kind of 10 on my money that's okay but
maybe i can get some leverage here maybe
i don't have to put all of the 10
million in maybe i could borrow some of
it and maybe i'll get a better return
that way so when it comes time to
closing when it comes time to closing so
i'm buying the assets so these are the
same assets that i'm buying and i'm
going to give them
and the money that i raise for these
assets are going to go to you the person
who started this business
so here are the assets so instead of me
putting up the entire 10 million dollars
what i do is i put up 1 million dollars
myself
so i put up 1 million dollars myself 1
million from
from me and i go to a bank and i say
look will you lend me nine million
dollars i'm gonna put a million dollars
on my own money will you lend me nine
million dollars to help borrow to help
buy this business for 10 million dollars
in the bank to say i don't know that's a
lot of money we're putting a lot of
money at risk and we'll say look you
could charge me a decent interest rate
maybe a 10 interest rate and this is a
super stable business so clearly i'll be
able to pay the interest on that money
from the business and if for whatever
reason i'm not able to pay the money you
can get the business so i'm essentially
giving you the business as collateral so
you find some bank to agree to it and so
they will lend you nine million dollars
they will not lend you nine million
dollars nine million dollar loan and
let's say that it is at a 10
10
interest level
so now after i have so 9 million from
the bank 1 million for me that goes to
you you can now
retire and buy your dream home or
whatever else you might have needed to
do with that money you could leave it
for for your for your children whatever
you might donate to charity whatever
floats your boat but now the capital
structure of the business looks like
this i now do have a lot of debt i
bought you out using leverage this is a
leveraged buyout
so now there is one million dollars of
equity that came from me and there's
nine million dollars of debt that came
from the bank
that's nine million dollars of debt
assets
at least what i paid for it was 10
million dollars liabilities are nine
million dollars what's left over is one
million and let's think about how this
investment assuming the business keeps
generating a million year let's think
about how good of a payoff this might be
for my 1 million dollar investment so
before i had a pre-tax income of 1.5
million so 1.5 million pre-tax
pre-tax before
now i'm going to have to pay some
interest
so now i'm going to have to pay so 9
million dollars at 10 percent that is
900 000
in interest
so now my pre-tax won't be 1.5 million
i'm also going to have to pay 900k in
interest so minus 900k
means that i have 600 000 so 1.5 minus
900k is 600 000
per year pre-tax income
six hundred thousand per year in pre-tax
income and then i will pay taxes on that
the cool thing about corporate interest
is that it's tax deductible it's
deducted from your pre-tax income so now
you take the 900 from the 1.5 you have
600 000 left over and then you pay taxes
on that and let's say it's still the
same tax rate so roughly one-third of it
goes to the government and so that you
are left with 400 000
net income and if you look at the math
this is actually a pretty good deal for
me or i should i i was saying you but
i'm the guy who bought it you were the
guy who sold me the business so this is
me now i am left with 400 000
net income per year which is pretty good
because i only made a one million dollar
investment so even though this looked
like a sleepy business even though it
looked like it was only getting a 10
yield on it because i was able to
leverage up i was able to do this
leveraged buyout i'm now able to make
four hundred thousand dollars per year
on a one million dollar investment and
now all of a sudden that is a not so
sleepy annual return